274 joyas precolombinas cada una con más
de mil años fueron repatriadas la semana
pasada desde Estados Unidos a Colombia
su lugar de origen se trata de finos
objetos y collares hechos de conchas que
fueron fabricados por comunidades
indígenas entre el año 50 antes de
Cristo y el 500 los artefactos habían
sido recolectados progresivamente por la
embajada de Colombia en Washington desde
2018 la mayoría fueron devueltos
voluntariamente por una mujer
estadounidense que los heredó de su
difunto esposo pero otros Fueron
confiscados por el FBI como parte de un
acuerdo entre los dos países para
devolver los objetos culturales que
hayan sido vendidos en el mercado ilegal
piezas que han sido recuperadas a través
de incautaciones piezas que han sido
recuperadas por devoluciones que se han
hecho de parte de coleccionistas que han
tenido digamos acceso a estas piezas que
han sido traficadas no producto de la
huaquería que han sido traficadas
internacionalmente y que
Hoy podemos
repatriar según Colombia esto es solo la
punta del iceberg ya que busca recuperar
otros 730 artefactos en todo el mundo
que aún necesitan ser repatriados